الحرب في اوكرانيا مستعره توازيها حرب
اخرى بين قاده اوروبا في خضم معركه ايراده
الجدل والاتهامات الموجهه لبرلين بالتقاعس
عن دعم كيف على منسوبها بين الحلفاء
الغربيين المانيا في الاتهامات تاره وتقول
انها ليست حجره عثره في طريق تزويد
اوكرانيا بالعتاد
في الوقت الحالي لم يتم طرح السؤال لكن
اذا طلب منا فلن نقف في الطريق الدبابات
المطلوبه ليس للتجول في الشارع
ليدافع الاوكرانيون عن انفسهم افهموا مدى
اهميته هذه الدبابات وندرك ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب نحن مع جميع شركائنا في عمليه
المشاورات
وتاره اخرى تدعو الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قرار ارسال دبابات اليو بارك سباي الى
الجيش الاوكراني فمصلحه برلين تتمثل في
اتخاذ القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر عليها
يقول وزير الدفاع الالماني
تردد برلين دفع بولندا الى الاعلان عن
تشكيل تحالف يضم البلدان التي تملك دبابات
اليو بارك والمستعده لتقديمها الى كاف
منتقده المانيا على اضاعه الوقت
الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو لم نحصل على هذه
الموافقه سنستمر في تسليم دباباتنا مع
الاخرين الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
التطورات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه المانيا
على حساب كل المعادلات وعدم التورث في حرب
مباشره مع روسيا الغاضبه تقارير ذكرت
النبرلين لن ترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا الا
اذا فعلت واشنطن الامر نفسه
بلال البوجدين العربيه